hello everybody and welcome to part 14
of let's play penumbra the Black Plague
actually I was informed it's not the
Black Plague it's black pig but I think
the Black Plague rolls off the done
better able open ought nothing on empty
people are good at filing oh yeah flare
I'll file my flare alright two more
flares I should use those robbed
microscope uh-huh no projector what do
we got what do we got whatever this is
oh it's a Swiffer
wiring I'm not touching that nah f that
suck out myself
why is she have one in here oh no she's
infected I knew it I knew it I knew it
oh she's so gonna eat my brains out hey
if you know it at me no not like that
bad way bad way oh what is that oh oh oh
tough monster baby fetus oh ah why did I
do that
oh oh oh I'm not you
Oh No light oh man
ah like yay painkillers all the music is
so soothing but I know that's just
trying to put me in a state of ease so
that can be scared more hello why did it
shake a lot of batteries the toilet
paper was in the toilet
toilet goes in the toilet paper
alright seizure-inducing light goes away
alright nothing in there where is she no
no oh no this is a trap
oh it's a trap give me some oh it's so
trap oh I'm scum oh there's a trap he's
gonna betray me
oh no hugs oh no hugs no hugs for me no
hugs from our aah oh no oh no oh it's a
trap it was a trap oh my god oh I need a
movie ba get out of here oh no oh no no
no oh man aw just spider Oh get away Oh
get away why it took me like a second to
realize it was actually gonna hurt me oh
no oh no oh get me out of here get me
out deal with that thing Oh what's in
here Oh what is this stuff you know what
you know I'm sick and tired I don't even
like you yeah
Oh Oh Pro dodge what's this oh I get it
come in all right no come in damn it
oh [ __ ] ow oh oh did it hurt Oh one more
to the groin have a real groin anymore
know what
Oh what the hell was that was it
this is where's this - oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah so we just get you in here
what's going on what's going on nothing
at all yeah yeah oh you want some Oh
dodge like a boss Oh close the door in
your face all right what's this let's
see good up there we go
oh I got dropping on your face so you
get right stunned
Oh like a bow what no give me a selfish
lemon Oh No why don't you Oh God
before you oh come on Lee
I know murder can be a lot oh [ __ ] you I
didn't you oh you son of a hey I think
that's a piece of oh I hate you so much
wait don't tell me you really thought oh
my new I'm pulling your leg I I can't
believe it I'm I'm so mad and all that
they did this oh this is worse you silly
I'm not Billy um I hate you so much I
hate you so much
at jell-o I want my hug oh this is ah
this is the worst it's worst oh I hate
myself I hate myself god oh this damn it
dad darn it No damn it damn it aah
alright God you didn't couldn't tell I
was upset by that
Oh angry newsy anger inducing whatever
alright huh
fine
I do yeah yeah I guess God God a key
phenomenal
oh why are they uh holding @p or a note
or a swipe card oh boy I don't know I
raised you voice more than ever I hate
so much I hate you so much
oh man whatever fine I'll touch the
things there's no hope for me so the
virus I don't care I don't care I don't
care I don't care just get me in get me
out oh man I'm gonna need to take a
break after this part ah yeah this is
the thing that the guy threw at me oh oh
ill layer batteries you can behind the
milk jug no not their batteries yeah
look like care anymore what I care fuzzy
pictures
uh boring oh shut up games on this thing
I don't care you got a hell and you die
cure all right acetone chlorine sulfur
iodine nitrogen okay I got five of those
okay
where's is store to in order
okay went to the that room there must I
must have missed one so let's see
I hope you're not talking to me god I
feel so bad oh I feel so bad
Oh what huh
oh man oh I'm so sorry I'm so sorry oh
I'm so sorry this broad we sorry you
kill her off I just still oh shut up
from beyond the grave populations likely
to work as a Roma therapies to cure
cancer oh I hate you so much
oh I hate you so much just diagnostic
execute Oh general status what's the
general status facility condition
critical no kidding yeah yeah yeah there
we go
that's phenomenal I like those odds I
can beat the odds
uh-huh uh-huh Oh
experimental humans visitor throughput
last new visitor me Oh someone exited
one me all year a year ago though I'd be
weird
thinking operational hey life support oh
boy
yep foods gone transports gone coms are
off
oh no internal security off plumbing yay
plumbing oh right the sewers are working
huh for more monsters to come through
and me to wade through [ __ ] okay oh man
Oh can't you just list it all out at
once I make me through go through all
this stuff investigation a tomb yeah
okay
research status uh-huh
uh-huh boring r12 - I don't know
shmoop up password
schmuck yeah I thought so
all right unlocked okay oh oh man I
still feel terrible
all right anyway I'll get over it
I'll get over it baby
all right boobs all right thanks for
watching this episode this horribly
depressing episode oh man so angry mad
and sad
all right anyway thanks so much for
watching I will see you in part 15 of
let's play penumbra the Black Plague bye
bye